what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
Sinestro Corps war god this story is so
good if the story is nuts it's
absolutely insane
this is just the prelude to this isn't
even like the main story this is just
the prelude and it's absolutely insane
this is one of the most bonkers stories
that I've ever read in a good way
in a good way it's crazy in a good way
it's it's crazy and it's exciting in a
good way
let us get into this let us cover this
so the cool thing about this is it's
like right off the bat we just get like
the motivations of Sinestro right I mean
Sinestro Corps you know the the yellow
lanterns we get his motivations right
off the bat and that's the cool thing
about this because the first thing we're
told is that like Sinestro he absolutely
abhorred anything that does not fall in
line with what he considers to be like
structure and regimen and we knew that
right like we knew the hold with the
whole story of Sinestro with him falling
for the Green Lantern Corps all of it
was rooted in the fact that where he was
the greatest member of the Green
Lantern's you know the greatest of their
kind one of the most capable he
eventually succumbed to fear the reason
being because of the fact that as a
Green Lantern he believed that there
needed to be absolute order there needed
to be absolute structure it was always
with the smallest thing it's like the
quintessential example of Batman about
why he doesn't kill all you have to do
is justify at once and then he can
justify it a thousand times over that's
the position of Sinestro like he took
his ring and he said we're going to
institute absolute order and absolute
structure on his home planet and then in
turn I tried to influence that across
the universe of course that led to the
to the guardians of the universe
realizing what it was that he was doing
casting him out of the Green Lantern
Corps and forcing him really to kind of
run into retreat eventually becoming a
bad guy and the most notable enemy of
Hal Jordan what this tells us is that
initially Heuer I guess initially where
he believed that he was doing the right
thing which is why he was able to invoke
willpower the way he was he eventually
realized that it was fear you know it
was fear of the fact that things that he
would basically lose what it was that
made him who he was you know that he
would lose control over his sector that
he would basically failed in his mission
not only that he came to believe that
because of the fact that he was able to
institute the kind of order that he did
that came from the fact that people were
afraid of him they feared for and so
that's when they begin to realize the
fear is the best motivation for forcing
people to do the things that you want
them to do and that's the coolest thing
about this
is because remember the emotional
spectra exists out there as this sort of
disembodied thing that basically is fed
by all beings in existence but it's only
until recently people learned how to tap
into it the guardians of the universe
learned it but in terms of other people
it's this little thing that happens
every once in a while you know for
example Atrocitus his whole family
slaughtered his entire sector is
massacred by the by the Manhunters and
he in turn in his rage and in his anger
is able to tap into the emotional
spectrum of rage which in turn allows
him to create the Red Lantern Corps of
course we'll get into that you know all
that stuff later on down the line
but for Sinestro feeding into his own
fear you know really kind of feeding
into the concept of fear itself he's in
turn able to tap into the fear aspect of
the emotional spectrum and then
effectively make himself the first of
the yellow lantern stop this is so cool
because remember over the course of this
whole idea of the Sinestro Corps growing
what we're told is that this little
segment of Sinestro basically forming
his core is basically a backstory it
takes place in the past what ended up
happening is in the modern day we know
that right now we're at least at the
time the stories being told but he sent
rings out to basically grow his Sinestro
Corps army and one of these rings had
approached Batman and said you have the
power to instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps and then
ultimately cast it out once it realized
that he had used the Green Lantern ring
of Hal Jordan and that's why we covered
a lot of that stuff because those things
were so important and they set the stage
for things that would come later on down
the line they were small moments there
were tiny little things that took place
but they all built to this greater thing
and that's how geoff johns wrote his
Green Lantern story if a thing would
happen in a panel or something would
take place in a page that would seem out
of place and totally unnecessary and
then like five or six stories later on
down the line the entirety of a set of
events hinders on what happened in that
one page and that's why this is so cool
man limitation geoff johns moon this guy
knows how to write stories but it's why
it's so cool because remember you know
what the whole secret society as it was
formed by lex luthor after i guess
before and during the events of Infinite
Crisis Sinestro would serve as part of
that group now of course we also saw him
yeah basically serving alongside eobard
thawne so on and so forth and the reason
why that matters is because following
the Sinestro Corps ring approaching
approaching Batman and trying to bring
Batman into its ranks Batman basically
went told the rest of the Justice League
something's going on I was approached by
the equivalent of what looked like Hal
Jordans ring except it was yellow
said welcome to the celestial core how
do and of course intervenes because
investigating and that was a whole idea
of what it is the green I'm sorry the
the Justice League is doing with eobard
thawne they're basically tracking down
all these leads on what the Sinestro
Corps is and what the Sinestro Corps is
about but no one has any answers to that
no one knows the answer to this riddle
now of course again transitioning over
to Kyle Rayner keep in mind with him we
know he's a on at this point in time now
explicitly what that means will actually
find out in this story which is what's
so cool but all we really know is that
as the torch bearer he basically holds a
place beyond all the other Green
Lantern's he doesn't require a ring in
order to do the things that he does not
only that he's basically the sole person
that's going to be able to bring back
all of the Green Lantern's and the
guardians of the universe should they
all end up being destroyed now again why
he's able to do that we'll get into that
in this video but him basically showing
up on coincides with you a little bit of
a conflict with a couple of lanterns but
the arrival of this green of this yellow
lantern ring which again says you know
you do not have the ability to instill
great fear you have not been chosen and
basically takes off and ends up going
and finding a suitable host now of
course Kyle Rayner follows them along
this path or at least follows this ring
to its most logical conclusion but at
this point we jump over to the guardians
of the universe and so of course
remember all this stuff takes place
after the events of Infinite Crisis and
so for those of you guys who were just
joining my channel who never went
through Infinite Crisis you'll find the
videos down in the description for a
more detailed explanation but the long
and short of it is that infinite crisis
serve the purpose of restoring the
multiverse that was basically it
you know crisis on Infinite Earths saw
the multiverse being eliminated in its
entirety and diamond was basically
replaced with a singular universe called
new earth infinite crisis saw the
multiverse brought back now this does
invoke the question of what happened
with one of the most notable members on
the multiverse which again we'll get
into that as we get to this story but
the fact remains that the way the
multiverse stands right now at least as
is explained to us by the other
guardians of the universe is that it's
really just kind of standing on a
knife's edge in the sense that you have
the main DC universe ended on top of
that or all these different earths and
so if the main DC universe earth were to
be destroyed it would send a cascading
event that would basically wipe out the
multiverse but the other half of this is
remember we dealt with the return of
cyborg superman and all we really knew
was that the cyborg Superman had been
defeated at some point in time his mind
had basically been stuck inside the
source wall the wall
that basically keeps the entire DC
universe contained but from that point
he basically resurrected himself restore
the Manhunters again you'll find all
this stuff down in the description and
then in turn basically began creating an
army for himself now of course the
Manhunter served as the group that the
guardians of the universe used before
they created the Green Lantern Corps in
the sense the Manhunters are basically
just robots remember the guardians of
the universe sat down and basically said
look if we're going to be the police
were so to speak of the universe we may
we're going to look around the universe
and do everything we can to keep it safe
we have to be impartial we cannot allow
ourselves to be governed by emotion and
so what we have to do is basically
separate ourselves from the entirety of
that ideology and so they basically
purge themselves of all emotion now what
this does is it basically says look with
them going through and creating the
Manhunters and and hunters basically
what a ride they rebelled the Manhunters
were decommissioned quote-unquote and in
the Green Lantern Corps was created in
place of the Manhunters and so that's
where the entirety of the Green Lantern
Corps comes from now following the
events of Infinite Crisis when the
multiverse was restored and the mind of
cyborg Superman was freed allowing him
to basically recreate his own body what
this meant was that cyborg Superman had
knowledge of the fact that the
multiverse was back he had knowledge of
what was beyond the main DC Universe and
all the other universes that were
available now the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that with
him showing up this basically begins the
process of fulfilling the prophecy of
blackest night now the prophecy of
blackest night is amazing and we're
gonna get into like the blackest night
story do that's oh my god man do
blackest night if God was right comic
books right now is what it would look
like right now
blackest night is so good it's one of
the best stories that I've ever read
like in general absolutely mind-blowing
like oh dude again spigots so cool
anyway the whole idea here is that this
begins a process of fulfilling the
blackest line and we're literally told
what it was you know a face of metal and
flesh itself shall speak the secrets of
the 52 the 52 new universes
you know fear will rise will power will
gather basically meaning that the
Sinestro Corps will begin to rise to
prominence and the Green Lantern's will
have to respond and a war of light will
unleash the truth behind the power of
the Ring this is the entirety the entire
basis behind the prophecy of the
blackest night now again this is
considered to be forbidden knowledge
this is something they don't
talk about it's it's the forbidden fruit
you know it's not something that the
guardians of the universe delve in now
of course the reason why this is
considered to be forbidden is because of
the fact that remember with a bandsaw or
have you been the Green Lantern that
passed his ring on to Hal Jordan a
bonsoir was told of the prophecy of the
blackest night by Atrocitus himself the
leader of the Red Lantern Court and so
because of all that again that stuff's
covered in my video on the secret origin
of Hal Jordan but because of that stuff
because of the fact that the guardians
of the universe don't believe it's real
they basically consider it to be
nonsense they consider to be an instance
of Atrocitus the red lantern playing on
the the idea of a dance or in the sense
of basically making him scared and
stripping him of his willpower because
remember a green lantern can only really
remain a green lantern and use their
rank to its full capacity so long as
they maintain willpower and they don't
allow themselves to succumb to fear and
so the Guardians of the Universe
basically looked at this prophecy and
said these are the ravings of a madman
Atrocitus an avid sewer were fighting
one another
Atrocitus at all there's a prophecy of
the blackest night hoping it would erode
the willpower of Adam Seward which in
turn would lead to him being unable to
defeat Atrocitus that's basically how
the guardians of the universe believe
this what we end up finding out is that
that's not true the prophecy of the
blackest night is very much true now
again one of the things that we also end
up doing is you basically pick up with
Guy Gardner kind of racing off and
talking to cilok who's basically again
this sort of a voice for the decisions
that are made by the guardians of the
universe and of course you know Guy
Gardner basically says look
sinestro's back Sinestro has returned we
have to figure out what's going on with
what he's what we're calling the
Sinestro Corps we don't really know what
it is or what it's about well in the
middle of this huge gathering with all
these Green Lantern's that have been
brought together by the guardians of the
universe suddenly a Sinestro Corps ring
appears and as it's going around hunting
for hosts it immediately realizes that
Kyle Rayner is there now this is cool
and this is what this is so interesting
when it comes to the Green Lantern rings
they're very linear right like they
don't really have like a mind of their
own I mean they do to a degree but like
if a Green Lantern gets killed the ring
will automatically go out and seek a new
house it'll say you know Green Lantern
of sector you know three four one six or
something like that
deceased seeking a new host and it'll
just race off and it'll find a new host
and it'll basically come across someone
that says you have great web power the
power to overcome great fear you have
been chosen welcome to the Green Lantern
Corps something
on those lines and it'll whisk him off
to OA to begin the process of being
trained now of course at that point they
can basically rebuke the ring and say I
do not want to be a Green Lantern and
the ring will choose somebody else but
in this instance the Sinestro Corps ring
when is hunting around immediately
recognizes Kyle Rayner is somebody
unique among all of the Green Lantern's
it captures him and it whisks him away
to the antimatter universe of the planet
of Court now again one of the things
that we needed to talk about here for a
second are the court Ian's themselves
this is really a Jeff John sort of
drawing on a lot of the old school Green
Lantern stuff in the sense that even way
back in the day before Jeff Jones came
along and before he revamped a lot of
these origins really telling the
backstory of Sinestro what we knew was
that where Sinestro was the greatest of
the Green Lantern's somewhere along the
line he got his yellow lantern ring and
what happened well accordions are
basically the ones that fashioned the
ring for him this ring that basically
fed on the color yellow because remember
back in the day you know that before
Jeff Jones took over back in the 60s and
70s really even the 80s and going into
the 90s there was no answer for why it
is that you know Green Lantern's are
weak to the color yellow
it's just they just are that's just
their weakness it's just the way it is
and so with Sinestro having a yellow
Lantern ring that allowed him to do
everything that a Green Lantern ring did
but basically defeat a Green Lantern
because the Green Lantern's couldn't
counter the color yellow in turn this
basically was establishes the idea that
the weaponers of core these people in
the antimatter universe basically a
different universe from the main DC
Universe itself
they basically fashioned this ring for
him now of course a lot of this was
included changed or eliminated with
regards to what it is that Jeff Jones is
doing now but the fact remains that when
Kyle Rayner is whisked off to the planet
core to this home base of where it was
that Sinestro was confined to when he
became a bad guy as a Green Lantern and
was held you know in a prison of sorts
by the guardians of the universe he
arrives to end up saying that all these
cord Ian's have been totally eliminated
and the reason why is because Sinestro
now has his army that measures and the
thousands there's thousands of yellow
lanterns everywhere I mean he's on a
planet surrounded by yellow lanterns
he's in what's probably the worst
situation that any green lantern could
be in and so because of this Sinestro
immediately grabs Kyle Rayner
says we're taking you you are going to
be a host for parallax the entity of
fear the embodiment of fear now this is
the process in which geoff johns begins
moving away from the idea of using
metaphors is saying like you know the
embodiment of fear in different things
like that and actually gives us physical
ideas physical constructs work high
weight or fights back as best you can in
the end he's just not able to pull it
off I mean the the yellow impurity is
basically gone I mean that was an
explanation that was given really in
green lantern rebirth whether it was
established that parallax is the living
embodiment of fear in the entirety of
the universe and parallax had basically
been defeated as some portal on the lawn
and was imprisoned in the Green Lantern
central power battery which is where all
the Green Lantern's get their power from
the reason for the yellow impurity
simply comes from the fact that spiral
action was inside the central power
battery eventually when you know how
Jordan more or less lost his mind
when he went through he became you know
he declared himself to be parallax all
that kind of good stuff and he was
possessed by the parallax entity the
idea was that when he destroyed the
entirety of the Green Lantern Corps
because parallax had bonded with Hal
Jordan parallax was no longer in the
central power battery and the reason why
this matters is because following the
defeat of Hal Jordan and Kyle Rayner
basically going through and resurrecting
the entirety of the Green Lantern Corps
and the central power battery this
basically brought them back without the
yellow impurity without you know
parallax inside the central power
battery which is why they don't have a
weakness to the color yellow that's why
all that takes place so for some of you
guys hopefully the light bulbs going off
you're just kind of like ok I understand
what's going on because that was
basically what was taking place it was
the idea of Geoff Johns sort of you know
fixing everything clearing everything up
and setting the stage for where we are
right now and so the crazy thing about
this is that while we have all these
different members of the Sinestro Corps
who have basically left the planet chord
and are assaulting OA the homeworld of
the Green Lantern's in the middle of
this whole conflict suddenly some 30 or
40 green lantern rings just go whisking
by talking about how their existing
lanterns have all been killed and the
question is well who was it that did it
you know if somebody went through and
killed all these Green Lantern's in one
shot then who was it that pulled it off
well we're now transitioning over to the
science cells only to find out that
superboy-prime is gone that's one of the
coolest things about this because
remember
videos on infinite crisis we had talked
about how superboy-prime had basically
become a bad guy you know he had become
a villain and in doing so at the end of
the entire conflict he was basically
encased in a giant box of pure willpower
by the guardians of the universe and was
kept in stasis was basically kept in the
presence of red radiation to keep him
from being able to use his powers and
keep him from being able to escape
that's how he's been held in prison this
entire time and so the idea seems to be
here that essentially
superboy-prime has been given a yellow
Lantern ring he's become part of the
Sinestro Corps and that's how he was
able to escape so the cool thing about
this is we switch back over to Sinestro
that's one of the really interesting
things here because Sinestro begins a
process of talking about how for him the
entire popularity are really the entire
idea of the Sinestro Corps it's
predicated on the notion of instilling
fear and so what they're doing is
they're basically going around and
gathering all these different people who
basically have the power to instill fear
in virtually any body across the
universe superboy-prime
would be the the swath that he cut
through the superhero community I mean
remember during Infinite Crisis Superboy
prom took on the Teen Titans Young
Justice and the Justice League all at
the same time I mean that guy was stupid
overpowered it was crazy but the fear
that he engendered was enough that he
caught the attention of Sinestro and
said that guy is a must not only that
with regards to Kyle Rayner being this
you know being ion and having the
ability to basically resurrect the Green
Lantern Court the reason for why this is
done is because he's the host for the
embodiment of willpower the ion whale
basically the Green Lantern whale that's
what he is and that's how he's been able
to pull off what it is that he's been
able to do we didn't know this this is
something that was basically introduced
to us there's like a fresh piece of
information prior to this all we knew as
the guardians of the universe just said
you will be the one who will bring back
the Green Lantern Corps should we all
die and we didn't know why with regards
to him being the host her willpower what
this means is that now in this instance
that this is how he's able to resurrect
and he's literally the embodiment of
willpower itself but if he's the host
for pure willpower he can be the host
for anything else it's like taking the
battery out of something and putting a
new battery in and that's exactly what
Sinestro does Sinestro says all you need
to do is feel fear if I can strip you of
your willpower if I can pull this living
embodiment of
power out of you then you have nothing
to feed on anymore you have no way to
keep your will going so all I have to do
is put something in its place now at
this point it's a roading whatever
willpower kyle rayner has left and this
is when Sinestro begins a process of
feeding on all the terrible experiences
the commoners had over the course of his
life the fact that his original
girlfriend was killed the fact that his
mother died all these instances are
saying these are all your fault you know
and so again what this whole whole idea
is basically saying is Kyle Rayner all
the worst experiences you've ever had in
your life are your fault and by making
him experience all these things it in
turn begins the process of eroding the
will power of Kyle Rayner which
ultimately makes him the perfect host
for parallax and that's what happens
parallax is let loose and the living
embodiment of fear across the universe
merges with Kyle Rayner making him the
new parallax and so what we end up doing
is of course we have Kyle Rayner
basically ask you the question when do I
get to kill folks and this is a hit this
is when Sinestro says you know we'll
start that soon in the meantime we have
to marshal our forces and so what we
learn is that in addition to
superboy-prime who looks amazing as a
yellow lantern by the way the
anti-monitor
has been inducted into the Sinestro
Corps the anti-monitor was resurrected
with the return of the multiverse Rimmer
the anti-monitor is intrinsic to the
multiverse itself if it's there he's
there it's just the way it works
and so the anti-monitor has effectively
been inducted into the Sinestro Corps
due to the fact that with the anti
monitors desire to basically absorb and
obliterate all life in existence and
recreate everything in existence he
instills fear better than most anybody
else
there's also cyborg superman because of
the fact that he instills so much fear
as being one of the most notable
villains following the death of Superman
so again the ranks are being grown the
numbers are increasing and what this
does is lead into this insane conflict
that's really one of the greatest
stories ever told like in the history of
comic books man if God was right in
Green Lantern right now is what it looks
like right now
if God was what man let's have some
church right now if God was right in
Green Lantern right now is what it would
look like right now this is one of the
best stories that I have ever read god
his story's amazing the story's
absolutely insane ah it is so cool
because it takes like what we think
about superheroes right and like it it
turns it on its head it takes everything
that we think about superheroes and just
like flips it over like the
crazy thing about superheroes and it
happens to degree but the crazy thing
about superheroes is that like
historically speaking there's like some
enemy that shows up and they're like oh
my god this into me who's really
powerful like there's no way we can beat
him but somehow like they come together
against impossible odds and they win
they save the day uh-huh no that's not
what happens that's not what happens in
here the whole first book of Sinestro
Corps war is just like find a place to
hide just go somewhere anywhere that's
not here like it's one of the coolest
things ever because remember in the
preload video we talked about how like
the Sinestro Corps was like always in
the background the Sinestro Corps was
always like mustering up its forces and
the background there were just times
when he would you show up in different
stories he would just have like a page
somewhere and it would just say you have
the ability to instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps and then
Odell would be it it would just go away
it was just vanished and the idea was
that it was building towards something
big man isn't a sight to behold it is
amazing the whole thing is that when the
Sinestro Corps was officially formed
they like raided oh I mean it was just
like just ripping apart the Green
Lantern's and that's what's so cool
about this cuz like superboy-prime
escaped and like cyborg Superman's gone
the anti-monitor is allied with the
Sinestro Corps imagine all the worst
things that could happen with the Green
Lantern's that's what geoff johns writes
from the story in the first part of the
story because initially is all just
recuperation right i mean like you know
on OA it's the idea that they were just
totally wrecked by the Sinestro Corps
with no expectation that it was coming
and that's the great thing about this is
no one knew it was coming no one had any
idea it was there they were just you
know meeting together and then suddenly
it was everybody who shows up these
members of Sinestro Corps just show up
and just start crushing everybody and so
at this point it's just like okay fall
back let's see if we can't get our
forces together let's see if we can't
figure out what's going on but in the
midst of all this like it's it's
something like 5556 the number just
keeps going up the numbers of lanterns
slain just keeps going up and that's the
whole thing because what they say here
is that like on Omaha the the assault of
the Sinestro Corps is basically stopped
because they were there to capture Kyle
Rayner I mean it wasn't expected but
when they found him there and found him
as the host for the will power entity in
the emotional spectrum they
took him to took him to court you know
with the antimatter universe and then
they backed off but across the universe
Green Lantern's are dying everywhere and
that's what makes this so cool because
it's like this huge and compensate opera
with everything that we see going on in
this story right now keep in the back of
your minds
Green Lantern's across the universe of
just dying it's one of the coolest
things in the world like you to see
these numbers just just cranking out you
know occasionally it's just you know 67
Lantern's dead or so on and so forth you
see rings fly by Green Lantern has
sectors such and such deceased searching
out viable replacement or ever the case
may be now the other half of this is the
book of OA and that's what makes this so
cool because remember the book of OA
serves as both a general guide as well
as a chronicle of everything that's gone
on and the whole history of the
guardians of the universe the Green
Lantern's all the forces they faced
Sinestro falling from grace all that
kind of good stuff but the idea is that
there's also the prophecy of blackest
night another cool thing about this is
that if you just suddenly jump into
Sinestro Corps war you could still kind
of you know get a general idea of what's
going on but it's a lot more fulfilling
and there's a lot more meat and potatoes
to it if you go through and start
reading the stories beforehand which is
why I always tell people if you're gonna
read Green Lantern and read Green
Lantern Corps and read Green Lantern go
all the way back you know really to
rebirth and just work your way forward
with regards to the whole Hal Jordan and
Green Lantern mythos but what this does
is it tells us that while all these
Green Lantern's are sitting around and
dying the guardians of the universe are
more or less playing politics now we
kind of expect that to be the case right
like we expect with the Guardians of the
Universe they're gonna be playing
politics they're gonna be doing their
thing where they're gonna be engaging in
bureaucracy and talking about what they
should do and all that kind of good
stuff and how things should happen and
function and so on and so forth but
remember the original idea of the
guardians of the universe is that they
would catch their emotions aside they
would basically say we are devoid of all
emotion whatsoever now of course again
we know right now just because of DC
rebirth the last will and testament of
the of the first Lantern we know all
that deals with the fact that they were
basically taught how to how to harness
the emotional spectrum by volthoom and
began to realize that tapping into their
emotions was too extreme and they
basically cast them aside and made
themselves just totally devoid of any
real feeling whatsoever
believing that strictly rational thought
would be the only way to go but the idea
was that with a bandsaw or being the
Green Lantern predecessor - Hal Jordan
which is to say the guy that basically
gave Hal Jordan his ring a dance or had
been told by Atrocitus the head of the
Red Lantern Corps of the prophecy of
blackest night
funny thing about this is the question
that you know that ganthet and sayd have
because remember the Guardians never
usually take names so it's basically
Jeff John's way of saying these two are
gonna play a very important role as we
go on throughout the Green Lantern
mythos but the argument that ganthet and
sayd have is look if the rest of the
Guardians consider the prophecy of the
blackest night to be nonsense if they
consider it to be just this sort of a
scare tactic that was used by Atrocitus
for the purpose of weakening the will
power of a band soar through fear and
then using that to defeat him then why
in the world did the guardians of the
universe record it in the first place it
would be like if I came to you and I
said oh man like the planets gonna blow
up tomorrow and you're like whatever
that's nonsense I don't believe a single
word of that and then you started making
arrangements in case the planet did blow
up if you didn't really think it was
real then why are you making these
arrangements in the first place and so
what this does is it basically reveals
to us the idea that while a lot of these
different guardians are more or less
hers of their emotions on a very
fundamental level on a very personal
level they're terrified they're
terrified of the idea that the prophecy
of blackest night is real that it's true
because if it is it means those
guardians are all gonna die
it means the Green Lantern's are all
gonna die it means there's gonna be
nothing but death and destruction across
the universe forever and ever and ever
and ever and so again it's the idea that
they're basically faced with their own
mortality and that's one of the reasons
why I love this little piece of writing
so much with Geoff Johns because it begs
the question if you were a race and it
basically been around for billions of
years and then we're suddenly forced to
face the idea that you're not as
omnipotent as you think you were and
that you can die just like anybody else
would you really be prepared would you
be absolutely terrified are you so used
to living but you can't imagine not
being alive and so again with help from
ganthet and sayd Hal Jordan has
basically informed that of course Kyle
Rayner is being held on court the home
base of the the Sinestro Corps at least
at this particular point in time now
keep in mind here Hal Jordan is kind of
like this Green Lantern that fell from
grace he's still considered to be like
the best of them in terms of what he can
do how he uses ring the fact that he's
like you know first one in last one out
that whole element makes him one of the
greatest Green Lantern's among them but
there's a lot who don't trust him
because remember back during my light
following the destruction of Ko city by
a by Mongol and cyborg he felt such a
rush of fear that he was basically taken
over by parallax the embodiment of fear
within the emotional spectrum he went
forward as a villain he basically laid
waste to the entirety of the Green
Lantern Corps killed the guardians of
the universe for a lot of Green
Lantern's out there they
look at him and what if it happened
begin and that's one of the crazy
scenarios that level of trust just isn't
there anymore and it never really will
be I mean the lost lanterns the ones who
were believed to have been killed by him
only to have been taken by cyborg
superman and used for experiments
eventually being rescued by you know Hal
Jordan and Guy Gardner and so on and so
forth they specifically will never trust
Hal Jordan again but they constantly
keep reminding of everybody of the time
that Hal Jordan became a bad guy the
time that Hal Jordan was evil you know
and so what goes on here in the middle
of all this
is that when you know Guy Gardner and
Jon Stewart and Hal Jordan go to charge
their rings in order to break the
interdimensional barrier and travel to
the antimatter universe and access court
we suddenly end up finding out that the
central power batteries basically been
booby-trapped and that's the coolest
thing because for years back before
geoff johns took over the idea was that
green lanterns were just weak to the
color yellow but nobody ever knew why it
was just something that they you know
they were just weak to it it wasn't
until geoff johns came along and said
the guardians of the universe discovered
parallax to represent the very
embodiment of fear they can find him
inside the central power battery which
in turn is the reason why green lantern
rings were weak to fear in the first
place weak to the color yellow in the
first place parallax was eventually
freed the yellow impurity went away what
it did is it created this kind of
scenario where as light parallax always
had a backdoor into the central power
battery not only that you also have to
keep in mind kyle rayner
was the host for ion he was the host for
willpower he's part and parcel to the
Green Lantern's themselves and so well I
wouldn't go as far as to say that the
central power battery is like an arm or
a leg for Kyle Rayner it's not that much
intertwined in who he is he's still very
much a part of the fact that it
basically came back and so he's almost
able to sort of enter and leave as he
wants to but creating this sort of booby
trap is perfect because what it means is
that any green lantern that goes to
charge their rings will get a direct
shot of fear into their bodies because
remember the central power battery is
this massive source of energy this
massive source of willpower so it would
be like you sticking your finger in
electrical socket except instead of
electricity you feel a rush of fear and
that's exactly what happened with Hal
Jordan where he's normally able to
overcome great fear where he's normally
one of the best of the Green Lantern's
he immediately experiences this massive
rush where he's basically forced to
relive the death of his own father and
what this does is it allows Kyle Rayner
to appear as parallax and basically
begin the process of taunting Hal Jordan
why whiskey
him away to the to the antimatter
universe of cord now something else to
point out here is that we get a couple
instances here and there of Green
Lantern's who were either trying to make
their escape who don't really know
what's going on who aren't aware of the
fact that the Sinestro Corps is
attacking and once they do show up
they're just totally obliterated and
that's the crazy thing about this
because remember the universe is a big
place and it takes time will you have
the Sinestro Corps launching a surprise
attack then it takes time to basically
marshal forces together to get
information out there to let people know
what's going on and some of the time
some of these Green Lantern's realize
what it is that's happening there
suddenly ambushed by like 50 members of
the Sinestro Corps and they have no hope
of escape now that's something else that
I want you to take note of here is
because we end up having Sinestro
travelling back to his home planet of
kuru ger and the reason why this is so
important is because of the fact he
basically visits cirrhotic not to the
girl who took up you know his own
lantern his own Green Lantern ring and
became the Green Lantern of kuru ger now
with her character being elevated to
this position it brought in one of two
possible scenarios the first was that
she never wanted to be a Green Lantern
in the first place just because of the
fact that she remembers when Sinestro
ruled over career and how of dictatorial
he was in his policies but the other
half of this isn't it terrified her
because she believed that people on
Krueger would view her the same way that
people would look around and say oh we
have a savior up there in the form of a
Green Lantern who's not Sinestro like
she'll lead us to the promised land
she'll give us a better society
she'll solve all of our problems for us
and that's what she was terrified of
because one of the things that's kind of
hit home when it comes to the Green
Lantern's is that the bet the people
that are best suited to be Green
Lantern's are the people who know how to
confront their own problems and know how
to deal with their own problems hence
the necessity of willpower the willpower
to overcome such overwhelming odds and
cope with them as best you can but for
cirrhotic her fear is basically becoming
Sinestro now really at this point it's
just a matter of the nature of the Green
Lantern rains and the fact that she's
just not as capable of a fighter as
Sinestro is now when I talk about the
nature of the Green Lantern rings
there's an instance when she tries to
kill Sinestro the problem with this is
the rain stops her because one of the
big weaknesses of the Green Lantern
rings is that initially they were
designed as a peacekeeping force as
opposed to a war force and so the issue
with this is that where she tries to
take out Sinestro the ring immediately
realizes her intention is based on
hostility her intention is based on a
desire to
kill and it keeps her from doing that
and that's the reason why so many of
these Green Lantern's are dying because
they're playing defense when they should
be playing offense because they don't
have a choice their rings will not allow
them to kill their rings will only allow
them to defend and so that's why this
whole first part of the story is just
running and hiding defending as best
they can
keeping the Sinestro Corps at bay
because the Sinestro Corps does not have
that limitation those rings allow it's
wheelers to just kill whoever it is that
they come across especially if they're
if they're Green Lantern's because
remember the Sinestro Corps feeds on
fear it's powered by fear what better
way to to really you know continue
powering the Sinestro Corps then to just
incite fear everywhere you go by killing
Green Lantern's in front of people by
killing them all over the place and so
some of these lost lanterns try to face
off against parallax as best they can
but at the end of the day they're not
really able to pull it off on their own
and so what is up happening is the group
actually takes up residence underground
they really just kind of scatter to a
couple different a couple different
areas but Hal Jordan a term or two they
actually end up taking up residence or
at least coming across a woman by the
name of Lysa Drac now if you're reading
Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern's are
from from DC rebirth she's very familiar
to you saw her in the first arc
sinestro's law you know she's a care to
the dates all the way back to Geoff
Johns run and she was originally
introduced as just like this chronicler
of the Sinestro Corps she basically kept
the book of Sinestro the book of the
yellow lantern and the Sinestro Corps it
was just like the book of OA except that
it chronicled everything from the
Sinestro Corps sod what this does is
basically just give us this massive
conflict again outside of Hal Jordan
himself this massive conflict from all
these different lanterns all across the
universe all trying to stem the flow as
best they can but at the end of the day
not being able to hold off all these
members of the Sinestro Corps now of
course with regards to Hal Jordan and
his guys you remember this is not them
engaging in conflict to kill this is
them trying to rescue people where they
can trying to grab those who have been
captured trying to save those Green
Lantern's who were out there in no-man's
land that don't know what's going on or
else ambushed by a ton of by a ton of
yellow lanterns recon and contained
that's all this is that's why there's
action but there's really more of like
dialogue because it's like what in the
world is going on everybody trying to
get a grasp on this situation now with
regards to the guardians of the universe
again what they start doing is talking
about the idea of
rewriting the book of OA now the reason
why this is so significant is because
the book of OA is designed to be this
sort of guarantee promise among the
Green Lantern's right like it's this
idea that like no matter what any Green
Lantern does no matter what takes place
their accomplishments their failures
those who fall from grace those who
achieve great things their recordings
will go in the book of OA it literally
exists just Chronicle everything that
goes on with the Green Lantern Corps and
so while some of these members of the
guardians of the universe talked about
rewriting the book of OA the concern of
ganthet and sayd as they're going to
ride out the prophecy of blackest night'
and so what that basically means is
these Guardians would be tantamount to
sticking their head in the sand like
ostriches while all hell just unfolds
around them believing that if they just
ignore it then nothing will happen to
them but that storms coming either they
can face it and be prepared or they can
hide from it and be eradicated and so
the idea is that from ganthet and sayd
perspective it's we gotta face this like
we got to be Pratt we have to we have to
realize this blackest night is coming
and when it does hell is coming with it
we have to be prepared for this and the
other guardians are just like no no no
if we ignore it it'll go away and so the
idea is that if they rewrite the Book of
Allah they'll basically remove the
prophecy of blackest night pretend like
it's not there despite knowing the fact
that it will be coming the entire time
it's going to be there the whole way now
of course again back with Hal Jordan and
his guys all they really do here is just
like free Guy Gardner and Jon Stewart
but Geoff Johns actually begins the
process of going through and introducing
the notion of a singular Lantern
wielding multiple rings now somebody to
point out here is this had not really
been touched on since the days of
Emerald Twilight that was really the
last time we'd seen anything like that
with Hal Jordan taking all the rings of
the former Green Lantern's that he
defeated you know and just kind of using
those rings for his own purposes sort of
supercharging his own Green Lantern
powers that was really the last time we
had seen that but it set the stage for
what Geoff Johns is doing now because
suddenly we're gonna start seeing Green
Lantern's wielding more than one Lantern
ring we're gonna see people like how
Lander who and who are the embodiment of
all the Rings so we're gonna see like
all these crazy scenarios with all these
different characters now the other half
of this is the anti-monitor
and really with the anti-monitor at
least you know in the inner sanctum of
the Sinestro Corps the antimatter is of
course going through and kind of
experimenting on the whole on ion the
living embodiment of willpower sort of
you know trying to either torture it or
gain information or at the very least
see if it can be you know
did and transformed into something else
the motivations I don't think are
entirely explained here but it's it's
the anti-monitor so we know that
whatever it is that he's doing it's bad
it's just you know villains stuff but in
the middle of all this Hal Jordan the
other Green Lantern's know those who are
left they all basically sort of race
into the scene they end up you know
grabbing the embodiment of willpower and
racing off because at this moment in
time the perspective of the Green
Lantern's is that if the embodiment of
willpower is destroyed willpower will go
with it now we know that's not the case
but at the time they don't know that at
the time all they know is that if the
embodiment of willpower is gone then
they'll be nobody to resurrect the Green
Lantern Court and that's the reason why
that's so important because with Kyle
Rayner he was ion he was the host for a
willpower and so when he was replaced as
the host for parallax what that meant
was that the ion whale was just kind of
floating out there in no man's land
somewhere but if the ion whales
destroyed there'll be nobody to
resurrect the Green Lantern Corps
they'll all be killed off and that'll be
the end of that and so really one of the
most important things to do is to grab
the host to grab the whale and get out
of there as fast as possible and that's
what they do you know they all basically
kind of grab these things just race off
but in these last few moments what the
Guardians do is they emerge from the
central power battery from their own you
know a little haven in there so to speak
and they basically say we've rewritten
the book of OA and we now have new laws
chief among them is the idea that the
Green Lantern rings are now capable of
lethal force the Green Lantern's are now
able to kill and that's huge because the
Green Lantern's can't believe it they're
just kind of like wow but what choice of
the guardians of the universe have when
you're a guardian is the universe you
look out and you see that Sinestro you
know a thousand ester has formed his own
Sinestro Corps is own Lantern Corps and
he's just laying waste to every single
Green Lantern that he comes across what
choice do you have the guardians of the
universe sit down and say we don't have
a choice if we're going to defeat the
Sinestro Corps we have to fight fire
with fire and so from this point going
forward the Green Lantern rings have now
had the whole hold on lethal force
that's been removed the Green Lantern's
are now allowed to kill members of the
Sinestro Corps okay so continuing our
discussion on Sinestro Corps war we get
into the superboy-prime one-shot now
this is kind of interesting and missus
story of course was written by Jay
jon's but this looks like it was
actually an editorial slash legal
mandate and its really kind of a funny
situation because during this time legal
arguments began to resurface between the
Siegel and Shuster families in DC
because remember they'd been suing DC
repeatedly over the idea over the rights
to Superman and Superboy but the idea
was that because Superboy prom was
basically a spin-off of the Superboy
concept the idea was that all properties
routed to or based off of the Superboy
idea ultimately belonged to Siegel and
Shuster and so what ended up happening
is DC actually had to change the name
because of the fact that they had
effectively kind of won this lawsuit
with regards to Superman all things that
were Superman related belonged to DC but
with Superboy it was still in contention
and so what they effectively did in this
story is they use it as a way to
actually change superboy-prime into
Superman prong now in truth it's really
just a name change that's really all it
is that was the only thing that was
really necessary in order to pull this
off the problem is that in the realm of
comic books you can't just simply change
the name of a character that wouldn't
have made sense for him just one day say
you know what I'm just gonna start
calling myself Superman prong just
because of the fact that DC already had
DC 1 million that line of stories was
already there and the concept of
Superman prime was already in existence
and so there had to be an explanation
that could differentiate between
superboy-prime now calling himself
Superman prime and basically Superman 1
million as it was kind of a cool idea in
terms of how this unfolded but what this
does is it actually initially picks up
with Superboy prom as part of the
Sinestro Corps visiting the grave of
Bart Allen now this again is really just
a reflection of editorial mandates and
the reason why I say that is because
Bart Allen was a character who
originally appeared in 1994 and he was
designed to be this attempt to sort of
reinvigorate and keep her keep
refreshing the idea of the flash
landscape remember after crisis on
Infinite Earths there was only Wally
West as the flash and then you just kind
of had newer members or I guess the
return of older members that were
gradually introduced as time went on but
Bart Allen was this descendant of the
flash family who had basically sort of
just kind of aged at an accelerated rate
but the idea was to basically provide a
new iteration of the kid flash going by
the name impulse who could be an updated
version of Wally West when he was a kid
before crisis on Infinite Earths the
problem with this was that as time
progressed and I'm not exactly sure why
this was done as time progressed the
she began the idea of basically removing
his character and this all basically
goes back to the introduction of a
villain by the name of inertia now
inertia was basically Thaddeus Thawne
the second and the way this worked out
was that in the 30th century in DC
Comics Thaddeus Thawne was a descendant
of eobard thawne and the idea was that
Thaddeus Thawne had basically become
president and it actually created a sort
of hybrid clone of Bart Allen and the
original eobard thawne combining their
DNA to create a singular being in the
form of inertia and what this did is it
allowed for inertia to operate as the
arch enemy of Bart Allen basically being
his own version of eobard thawne but
again well I'm not entirely sure about
like the sails or the the whole reason
why this was done all I really know is
that DC had come along and basically
told the writer at the time Marc
Guggenheim that he needed to eliminate
Bart Allen and so the story that was
written to pull this off was basically a
story called flash the fastest man alive
and what basically ended up happening
here is inertia developed a way to
effectively strip Bart Allen of his
access to the Speed Force basically
making him normal at the same time it
also coincided with inertia teaming up
alongside the Rogues and so because the
Rogues are basically the main enemy of
the flash itself according to editorial
mandate the story had to conclude with
the Rogues killing Bart Allen now again
I don't know if this is really character
assassination I don't know if it was the
idea that DC just wanted to get rid of
him and truth as far as I'm aware it's
just speculation I'm sure there's some
source out there somewhere that explains
that but I haven't been able to find it
I haven't been able to find any
indication or any line-by-line
explanation of why BC chose to make this
choice but the fact remains that because
Bart Allen was one of the flashes who
had originally defeated Superboy pran
during the events of Infinite Crisis it
created a sort of bitter anger a bitter
hatred between the two of them
especially because of the fact that
Superboy prom is terrified of speedsters
now the only indication of his fear of
speedsters really coming takes the form
of the idea that they were able to push
him into the Speed Force not only that
the speedsters derived their power from
the Speed Force itself and so it's not
like another dimension I mean it is to a
degree but it's not it's not like
pushing him into a different universe
it's not like putting him on earth two
or something along those lines and the
Speed Force all time is kind of relative
so for superboy-prime where he was gone
for like a day or an hour or something
along those lines in the Speed Force he
was there for years and so it was
effectively kind of like this living
prison where he can't access see or talk
to
anybody the other half of this is the
motivation behind Superboy prompt
remember he's a tragic character the way
that he was written in Infinite Crisis
made him a very sad character for those
of you guys who never saw my origin
video on him he basically came from
Earth Prime that was part of this huge
multiverse that existed before the
events of crisis on Infinite Earths an
earth prime in DC Comics it's basically
the real world it's the world where
you're sitting watching this video right
now and so superboy-prime growing up in
this universe basically read comics
about superheroes he read comics about
Superman you know during the Golden Age
you know Superman as he appeared in DC
Comics is one of those weird
meta-commentary kind of things but he
was basically hit with cosmic energies
with the energies of a comet and he
granted him powers that made him
equivalent to Superman the other half of
this was that because kryptonite didn't
exist in earth prime and because of the
fact that his reality of Earth Prime was
destroyed and the events leading up to
crisis on Infinite Earths superboy-prime
basically had no weaknesses aside from
red Sun radiation and even then his
strength level his endurance his speed
it was all well beyond the idea of any
of the Superman or superwoman who
existed at the time and so where he
basically was kind of shunted off to a
pocket universe after the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths
and then returned during Infinite Crisis
of course again we have those videos
down in our playlists about DC rebirth
you're welcome to check him out the idea
here was that he emerged as essentially
a bad guy because with him growing up in
reading superheroes as these beings to
look up to and then seeing this new
earth continuity this post crisis on
Infinite Earths landscape having
superheroes become darker a little more
gritty he basically came to believe that
the superheroes as they existed were not
real superheroes they were liars there
were frauds they were tricksters and so
the goal was that when he came out of
the Paradise dimension when he punched
reality and shattered it he ended up
just waging this war against all the
superheroes across the DC Universe and
literally crushing everybody I mean
there was a point where he faced off
against like 33 Green Lantern's and
killed them all it was absolutely insane
ultimately it took the efforts of the
original Golden Age Superman and the new
earth Superman to fly him through a red
Sun strip him of his powers and then the
Green Lantern's to encase him in this
giant green box one of the science cells
they have to basically keep him held but
remember during the events of I guess
part of the lead up to Sinestro Corps
war he was freed from this and he
inducted into the Sinestro Corps proper
now the biggest issue about this little
tidbit of storytelling here is that he
still uses this modified suit that he
used during our Infinite Crisis that's
designed for the purpose or at least
seems to be designed for the purpose to
harness yellow energy now the problem
with this is that Geoff Johns kind of
gives us this weird scenario here when
superboy-prime used this mechanized suit
of this powered suit during the events
of Infinite Crisis the goal was to
basically have the suit serve as a
battery pack of sorts in the sense that
all Superman are all versions of
Superman's superwoman whatever the case
may be they act as a solar battery and
so their body basically absorbs solar
energy until it can't hold anymore and
once their body's supercharged once it's
fully charged the solar energy they're
as powerful as their as they're ever
going to be they reach the peak of their
complete and total potential what
superboy-prime did in developing this
pack was basically give himself
additional solar energy which means that
he could fight longer and he could fight
harder than any of the existing Superman
that stood out there this compound of
the fact that he was already stronger
than any of the supermen that existed
out there so he was basically a one-man
army he was just an absolute wrecking
crew well of course with this armor
basically being destroyed with him
losing his powers after being locked at
a science cell and then being freed by
the Sinestro Corps this suit is not
exactly like the one he wore before but
it seems as though it would serve the
same the same purpose the problem with
this is that while he's going against
the combined efforts of like the Titans
and the Teen Titans and all these
different superheroes he keeps making
reference to the idea that he's waiting
for the Yellow Sun to come up now again
this is kind of a weird scenario because
historically speaking in DC Comics the
atmosphere of the earth plays no part in
the Yellow Sun in terms of how it
impacts a Superman whether Superman is
standing on earth or whether he's
floating out in space the impact of
Yellow Sun radiation is always the same
now the closer he gets to the Sun and
the longer he spends inside the Sun and
the more powerful he'll become that's
one of the reasons why Superman
one-million was so powerful because he
literally just stayed inside of the Sun
and so his cells were just soaked with
yellow sun radiation with regards to
this here it basically looks like
Superboy crimes not nearly as powerful
as he would normally be but the idea is
that if he's not as powerful as he would
normally be why wouldn't he just go to
the Yellow Sun and then show up on earth
fully charged we don't have an answer to
that question
instead we just kind of have to go on
the idea that he's not normally as
strong as he should be
but once the yellow Sun comes up it
basically allows his energies to begin
recharging again now in truth drawing on
the nature of this story and what we're
seeing with him you know kind of
reflecting on his own life reflecting on
these moments that he's had you know
with regards to Laurie his girlfriend on
earth pran lamenting the idea of the
destruction of his own earth the idea
that he basically allied himself with
the Sinestro Corps just long enough to
allow the anti-monitor a moment of
victory so that he could snatch it away
and kill him the implication seems to be
here that this suit maybe reduces his
powers or this super haps blocks out the
Yellow Sun radiation to a degree or it's
just for the sake of storytelling it's
just for the sake of giving us a chance
to see him kind of talking about these
moments and to see him face off against
some of these superheroes because
remember if superboy-prime
suddenly showed back up on earth at the
same power level that he was before he
would have destroyed all these
superheroes without any questions they
all would have died and so the idea is
that once we have the arrival of Charon
star of the Power Girl the super girl
basically of Earth - alongside Superman
and the Supergirl of the main DC
Universe this leads into the three of
them trying the best they can to hold
off Superboy pron now of course once the
Sun comes up his powers begin returning
to him in full force and he is
completely energized and so what this
means is that what little chance these
superheroes had to actually win is gone
they basically have no real chance
anymore now in terms of evolving him
from superboy-prime into Superman prime
this comes by way of the narrative that
he's basically been offering over the
course of the story because remember his
whole life is the idea that he's come to
believe that superheroes as they exist
in DC Comics at the time this story has
been written are not actually
superheroes because in the mind of
superboy-prime
there's no moral ambiguity when it comes
to superheroes it's we're good guys
they're bad guys we fight them we arrest
them they go to jail done and done
that's it there's no sometimes we can
bend the rules sometimes we can break
the rules we hide things from our
friends that's not how superboy-prime
views superheroes give you superheroes
as being 100% in the right always doing
the right thing
no matter the circumstance now again
doctoring that infinite crisis line of
stories that was designed to be a meta
commentary on superheroes as they
existed at the time by Geoff Johns
himself in a lot of ways Superboy
was Jeff John's as he was looking at the
superhero world but the overall idea
here is that because superboy-prime
viewed these heroes as morally ambiguous
the goal was to basically take the place
of Superman to eliminate this version of
Superman and replace him and that's why
he ends up calling himself
Superman prong because there was a time
in his history when he was a
superboy-prime but the reason for that
was because of the fact that he had
fought alongside the original 1940s
earth-2 Superman
that was a Superman he looked up to he
had no desire to take his place he had
no reason to take his place because that
was a superhero that superboy-prime
idolized but with the death of the
original Earth to Superman with him
being removed from the equation
now there's pleasingly a place for
superboy-prime to say I am going to
become the real Superman as he should be
I'm going to become Superman as a hero
should actually be now we know just by
virtue of the evolution of his character
he's twisted and he's basically lost his
mind but the fact still remains that
there was a lot of moral ambiguity when
it came to these heroes and so
ultimately he ends up just stripping off
the Sinestro Corps uniform which
coincides with the arrival of the
anti-monitor
with the Green Lantern's so on and so
forth and simply just dubs himself
Superman prime and so what this does is
this segues directly into the second
part of Sinestro Corps war and we
basically end up having Superman Prime
facing off against the ultimate weapon
of the of the Green Lantern's which of
course comes in the form of I on the
current host of the will power entity in
the green lantern of course this is
actually a guy named sodam yot it's
actually not kyle rayner because
remember Kyle Rayner is still part of
the Sinestro Corps what this story does
is we start to get back into this is it
basically picks up with a character by
the name of sodam yacht now this is kind
of cool because his character is really
introduced to basically show us how bad
things are getting for the superhero
community and a lot of this really deals
with the idea of a kind of cybernetic a
sentient planet called ranks and ranks
was basically this character that it
appeared over the course of DC's
publication history something like 10 or
20 times it was never a prominent thing
and the idea here was that ranks was
basically a planet that served the
purpose of kind of being a place for
villains and different folks to show up
in the idea was it eventually it led to
a conflict between Guy Gardner one of
the Green Lanterns of Earth and ranks
itself which saw ranks defeated and so
what this did is it Segway directly into
Sinestro Corps war in the sense that
ranks basically allied itself with
Sinestro if for no other reason than to
see Guy Gardner and the Green Lantern's
defeated now the reason why this matters
is because of the fact that the Green
Lantern's themselves have mow go and mow
go as crazy as it sounds is just a giant
planet with a Green Lantern ring and I
know it sounds kind of crazy but mojo is
insanely powerful because the abilities
of a Green Lantern are directly
proportional to the mass of that Green
Lantern to how strong their willpower is
the energy they can muster and so on and
so forth and so a person like Hal Jordan
for example wouldn't be as powerful as
someone like Mogo because Mogo is
basically a planet with the power of
willpower just being blown in any one
particular direction and so for the most
part Mogo could obliterate virtually
anything in its path but the reason why
this is important is because of the fact
that MO goes basically the Forward
Operating Base in a lot of ways for the
Green Lantern's in the sense that where
the Green Lantern's home base is OA
proper basically the home of the
guardians of the universe
Mogo serves as a way for them to just
kind of travel around for them to peruse
the area to keep their sectors so on and
so forth but he's also a very powerful
ally and with ranks being allied with a
Sinestro Corps this basically leads to
the two of them coming into direct
conflict now the reason why this is
important is because while Mogo can use
its power to totally obliterate ranks
there's also other Green Lantern's in
the vicinity and so really it would just
kind of result in collateral damage and
so what is up happening here is we
actually have sodam yacht alongside a
handful of other Green Lantern's make
their way on to rents now the thing
about soda yacht and we'll get into him
here in a second he's really kind of
introduced as this question of what
would happen if Superman got a Lantern
ring a Green Lantern ring that's really
the idea here because remember all of
this is really hitting home to the
notion of like the members of the
Justice League getting in their own
Lantern race this massive war between
all these different Lantern cores and so
once ranks is basically defeated by
having its central core over overloaded
which results in its explosion so dumb
yada of course revealed to have survived
the whole experience only for Hal Jordan
to chime in with the other Green
Lantern's and say that the target of
Sinestro is not OA as they believed it
was instead it's the planet Earth and so
what this does is it picks up with
superboy-prime
now the funny thing about this when it
comes to superboy-prime we're kind of
backtracking a little bit here the
superboy-prime one-shot sort of
coincides with this part of the Sinestro
Corps war but
where it fits in it's really kind of up
to us and it really it just kind of
comes almost immediately after this one
particular comic that we're gonna be
going through here in a second and of
course you know I'll mention as we as we
pass by where it is that it goes in but
the arrival of the Sinestro Corps really
is just like this absolute state of
pandemonium for the planet Earth because
remember despite all these different
superheroes that are there you know
Superman and Batman is so on and so
forth they didn't really know everything
that was going on with Sinestro that's
one of the big things that we had talked
about in the first part of Sinestro
Corps war about how they were in the
middle of a conflict and then seemingly
out of nowhere
Batman was met with a yellow Lantern
ring that said Bruce Wayne you have the
power to instill great fear after which
the ring abandoned him because it since
the fact that Bruce Wayne had used the
Green Lantern ring at some point in time
and considered him to be tainted but
despite this one little occurrence the
Justice League didn't know everything
that was going on out there in the
universe and so the arrival of all these
Manhunter robots under the command of
cyborg superman all these different
members of the Sinestro Corps heralds
just this massive invasion of planet
Earth now keep in mind I mean these
aren't weaklings you know Power Girl
basically this alternate reality version
of Supergirl Supergirl herself from the
main DC Universe Superman Batman so on
and so forth they're all able to
basically use their abilities to stem
the tide of this conflict but there's so
much happening and they can only be in
so many places at once and so one of the
things that actually ends up happening
here is we have Hal Jordan tracking down
and chasing down Kyle Rayner because
remember at this point in time Kyle
Rayner is basically the host for the
parallax entity
he's literally walking fear and so
because of this warehouse worden is able
to track him down and is able to grab
him ultimately parallax absorbs Hal
Jordan as well and so again this creates
for a pretty dangerous situation just
because of the fact that keep in mind
how Jordan had declared himself to be
parallax way back in the 1990s during
the events of Emerald Twilight and so in
this story when they're referencing
things about how Hal Jordan betrayed
them and so on and so forth it was the
idea that Hal Jordan had become the host
for the parallax entity before and so
with parallax basically possessing both
Kyle Rayner and Hal Jordan two of their
best Green Lantern's are now off the
table not only that all the experience
and all the knowledge that goes with
them is absorbed by parallax as well and
so it means that parallax now knows how
to counter all these different Green
Lantern's now of course again it's
really kind of like this massive arrival
all these heroes because in addition to
the Justice League facing off against
these ancillary members of the of the
Sinestro Corps they're also forced to
face off against superboy-prime and it's
absolutely amazing the way this happens
jumping into parallax himself it gives
us a little bit of insight as to what
happens when a person is possessed by
parallax and so for Kyle Rayner he's
kind of in this world of darkness and as
is depicted it really seems to be more
of like a psychological mind state you
know more so than anything else but the
fact remains here that with Hal Jordan
being absorbed as well the two of them
are basically able to use their
willpower and overcome parallax and
again that's the weakness of the
Sinestro Corps is the fact that if
anybody has sufficient willpower they
can overcome the Sinestro Corps they can
overcome the yellow lantern ring and
return to their normal cells and of
course with Hal Jordan and uh Kyle
Rayner working together they're
essentially freed of the parallax entity
now of course with parallax intended to
basically consume or you know possibly
destroy them both it just meets with the
arrival of a ganthet and sayd a couple
of the guardians of the universe who of
course grab or end up taking elements or
I guess really kind of splitting up Hera
lakhs and then dispersing him among
these different lanterns which of course
means that now parallax is effectively
held prisoner instead of just being in
one central place he just kind of spread
around different lanterns so it's really
just a way to kind of remove him from
the landscape temporarily and allow the
story to focus on everything else that's
going on and so again you know kind of
transitioning back to this major battle
to this major conflict we also end up
joining up with sodam yot himself and
again the idea is that once everybody
realizes what's going on with regards to
Sinestro targeting earth this is when
they also begin to realize about the
return of the anti-monitor
now a lot of people knew about that but
not everybody did and the return of the
anti-monitor is huge because we're
talking about a level of power that's
near godhood if not on the same level
the anti-monitor is virtually
unstoppable just completely
indestructible the yellow Lantern Corps
I guess the yellow Lantern ring doesn't
really do much for anti-monitor really
anti-monitor just kind of exists for the
purpose of fueling the fear of Sinestro
which allowed him to create his own
yellow Lantern Corps in the first place
but really I mean if you were to give
you know the anti-monitor a yellow
lantern ring it wouldn't make any
difference it wouldn't matter I mean
he'd still have an insane amount of
power it might complement those
abilities but given the power that he
has he doesn't need a yellow Lantern
ring it's kind of what I'm hitting home
at here and so with him being on the
scene the Green Lantern's also begin to
realize just how dangerous everything is
but this is when we queue into the
arrival of so demure and so demure kind
of pops up on the seam and basically
becomes the new house for the entity of
willpower for ion now the reason why
this is so significant and the reason
why this is so big is because this leads
us directly into the whole idea of the
prophecy of blackest night with regards
to the the I guess the one shot of
superboy-prime fitting in between these
two little segments here we basically
pick up after superboy-prime it fought
and wrecked all these different
superheroes and the idea is it's
superboy-prime
facing off against sodam yacht it's kind
of complemented by soda I'm talking
about the whole event and running it
over in his mind and commentating and so
on and so forth but it also gives us a
little bit of insight into his character
and what happens here is DC basically
goes back and grabs the idea of a place
called dachshund now dachshund was
basically a planet that was introduced
in 1963 and Action Comics number 312 I'm
not gonna swear to that though but it
was created by a guy named Edmund
Hamilton and Emin Hamilton had found his
claim to fame in science fiction novels
and so he was very big on writing
stories that dealt with spacefaring
adventures and things like that and
because of the fact that that sci-fi had
overtaken the popularity of comics of
superheroes in the 1950s it made sense
that if DC was trying to re instigate
her trying to reinitiate this second
renaissance of superheroes in the 1960s
that they would in turn grab science
fiction writers to pull it off and so
dachshund was introduced essentially as
a planet that was colonized by a group
of Kryptonians that had broken away from
Krypton proper and so what this did is
it introduced the idea that there could
be another Superman out there if he was
exposed to a Yellow Sun now the origin
that was originally given given to us in
1963 was a little bit different the one
that I just kind of ran over is
basically the one that we get in this
particular story but notice this
conflict between superboy-prime and
sodam yot despite the vast power that
sodam has he's basically channeling
willpower in its most pure form he's not
like a Green Lantern using his ring to
access willpower he is willpower he's
getting totally obliterated by
superboy-prime it's almost not even a
conflict here it's almost not even a
battle it's just absolute destruction on
an incredible scale not only that we
also sort of harken back to this origin
story of sodam which is actually really
really amazing and again it really
focuses on this idea that over the
course of their existence on DAX on the
inhabitants as they call themselves
daksa mites eventually became afraid of
anything that didn't hail from their
planet as the result is that they became
extremely isolated from the rest of the
universe and never really traveled
outside their own planet now the idea of
soda masks he existed was that he was a
kid who basically looked to the Stars
always wanted the idea to achieve
something greater and so the overall
goal here is that eventually he's met by
an alien that crash lands on the planet
the two of them began to talk and sort
of you know exchange ideas and learn
what the others used to only force
Odom's actions to be discovered by his
parents and then for this alien to
basically be taken and to be killed and
then used as propaganda at the same time
sona's mind is just kind of wiped or at
least modified forcing him to come to
the belief that the arrival of an alien
would simply be the herald of
destruction for their planet again more
or less brainwashing that's going on
here but where his parents had hoped
that sodam yahwah basically abandoned
the idea of looking to the stars you
know wanting to move beyond their planet
and focus strictly on the role that his
race was supposed to play instead he
basically said no and it instilled in
him an increasing fire to get outside of
the world and to go see what was out
there but where he'd finished building
the ship that's basically coincided with
the arrival of a Green Lantern ring
because of his willpower because of his
ability to overcome fear fear of the
unknown ultimately it led to him
becoming a Green Lantern himself now
again the reason why this is important
is because he has Kryptonian heritage
and that's one of the things that he
talks about as he's commenting on this
fight with a superboy-prime he starts to
talk about the idea of you know when he
was basically met by the guardians of
the universe they said look you are part
Kryptonian when you're exposed to the
yellow sun radiation of Earth's Sun
you're gonna start getting powers but
this is kind of cool because he doesn't
have the ability to learn how to use
those powers I mean if he if he wasn't
in the middle of a fight for his life
against superboy-prime
sure Superman could sit him down and
teach him hand it how to use the various
abilities that he has but he's basically
learning what he's able to do as he's
fighting the problem with this is that
he's facing off against superboy-prime
and superboy-prime has a wealth of
experience under his belt he fought
during crisis on Infinite Earths which
means that superboy-prime had faced off
against the anti-monitor superboy-prime
had helped who would instigate all the
events of Infinite Crisis and has fought
and defeated the entirety of Earth's
superhero roster on two separate
occasions this is not some kid who's
just kind of running amuck and being
angsty this is a kid that's got all
kinds of problems but he's also
battle-hardened and so that's
makes us so cool is because despite the
fact that sodam yacht does everything he
can to try to face off against
superboy-prime in the end there's
nothing he can do he just cannot hold
his own the other reason why sodam yacht
is so important is because it actually
sort of transitions to this extra nature
of this discussion that takes place
between ganthet and sayd and the Earth's
Green Lantern's was just to say Hal
Jordan Jon Stewart Guy Gardner and Kyle
Rayner and what is up happening here is
ganthet and sayd basically revealed the
idea of the prophecy of the blackest
night and this is why so dumb yacht was
so important because if so dumb yacht
were to be killed by superboy-prime it
would fulfill the first stage of the
prophecy now the prophecy of blackest
night isn't necessarily the prophecy of
the Black Lantern rings at least as is
given here the prophecy of blackest
night is the idea that there will
basically be a rise of six new Lantern
cores in addition to the Green Lantern's
now one of the things is established
over the course of geoff johns run is
that these different Lantern cores some
of them had existed for thousands and
thousands of years if not millions of
years others are cropping up for the
very first time the Green Lantern's had
existed since the time the guardians of
the universe made them you know however
many thousands of years ago with regards
to the star sapphires they've existed
for quite some time as well the red
lanterns they existed for a pretty
lengthy time but when it came to the
idea of the Sinestro Corps that's still
pretty new things like the orange
Lantern ring you know that one seems
pretty new the idea of the Blue Lantern
ring of Hope that one hasn't even been
made yet but the overall prophecy is
that all these lanterns are all these
Lantern cores these seven Lantern courts
will eventually come together and they
will engage in a conflict that will
essentially lay waste to the entirety of
all emotion across the universe now so
the prophecy of blackest night basically
foretells a circumstance where all
emotion across the universe will be
totally gone now in terms of what
blackest sign actually is as the story
and what the prophecy really means that
all unfolds in the actual blackest night
story itself which is amazing but the
fact remains here that in the middle of
this conflict ganthet and sayd basically
kind of bail out they're like look we're
not allied with any one particular to
the earth superheroes or so on this is
your fight you guys have to go deal with
it we are essentially outcasts in the
guardians of the universe we're here to
help provide guidance but not really
here to fight when it comes to all these
different you know members of the
Lantern cores and the Sinestro Corps and
the Green Lantern Corps is facing off in
the end
entire conflict really seems to kind of
turn keel and face on the idea of the
anti-monitor and of course the reason
for this is because of the fact that
with the sinestro corps members learning
that the Green Lantern can now kill that
they've basically been authorized by the
guardians of the universe to start
killing Sinestro Corps members some of
them run some of them are just like we
gotta go they just bail out others died
in the conflict and some are still
fighting but the fact remains here that
with the anti-monitor himself he's the
most credible threat and the reason for
this is because of the fact that the
anti-monitor basically channels
antimatter energy and so it would be
like if your left fist was antimatter
and your right fist was positive matter
and they punched they would cancel each
other out and so the idea of the
anti-monitor unleashing all this
antimatter energy is to quite literally
lay waste and completely obliterate the
universe and then travel into the
multiverse and do the same thing and
that's exactly what the anti-monitor
would do that's the reason why the
anti-monitor allied itself with Sinestro
was to be able to achieve this goal
because Sinestro basically said look
we'll clear the landscape of superheroes
and will allow you to go do your own
thing the other half of this is that
even with the superheroes facing off
against anti-monitor as best they can
they still can't hold their own now of
course with Kyle Rayner being freed of
parallax as Hal Jordan being free to
free to parallax and all these different
guys this basically leads to several
fights all coinciding at the same time
for example with the idea of war world
basically this giant planet this forward
operating base of sorts that's used by
Sinestro for the purpose of allowing US
forces to muster into a single location
and then launch an attack on earth it's
essentially this massive powerhouse of
energy because on world world resides
the Sinestro Corps central power battery
basically the source of all their energy
and so it's basically this massive bomb
this massive explosive device so the
idea of the Green Lantern's is to use
this to basically hit the anti-monitor
with the full brunt of all fear across
the universe and then hope to obliterate
them in the process at the same time
because of the fact that Kyle Rayner and
and Hal Jordans rings have lost their
power owing to the fact that the
Manhunter robots have the ability to
absorb green lantern energy this also
leads to all these different things kind
of winding down and coming to a close
for example with hank henshaw
when this massive Warworld bomb is
dropped on the anti-monitor or at least
is hit into him the idea of hank henshaw
is that he'll finally be able to die and
that's one of the most tragic things
about this because remember when Hank
basically became cyborg superman before
the events of the death of Superman
leading into the events after the death
of Superman he was a non remorseful
being all he wanted to do was just
destroy things but the idea was that he
had basically been faced with the notion
that he had lost everything he loved and
cared about when he became cyborg
Superman and so he'd essentially been on
this quest to die and the idea was that
he had allied himself with the
anti-monitor and Sinestro because the
anti-monitor said when this is all done
I will kill you you will finally be
freed of your imprisonment as it was
kind of an ironic thing because
ultimately it's the Green Lantern's that
seem to be engineering the process by
which cyborg superman will die when he
puts him into the direct path of the
explosion of war world hitting the
anti-monitor as it was really kind of a
bittersweet little thing it's actually
kind of an interesting little moment
here but with Sinestro sort of coming
down with the intention of using his
Lantern ring to take out Kyle Rayner to
take out Hal Jordan they in turn
reprogram one of these Manhunter robots
and absorb the the yellow lantern energy
of Sinestro now this is not a great big
huge thing but what it does do is it
allows for a direct hand-to-hand fight
between the three of these guys now the
reason why this is important is because
remember Sinestro had been a longtime
enemy of Hal Jordan they had fought for
years and years and years and years but
when Hal Jordan declared himself
parallax essentially killed Sinestro
only for Sinestro to basically survive
the experience to be resurrected and
then in turn become an enemy of Kyle
Rayner this is the one theme that both
have in common
Kyle Rayner and Hal Jordan have both
called Sinestro their mortal enemy and
so it's really just kind of like this
knock-down drag-out fight between the
three of them at the same time
superboy-prime
is taking no prisoners I mean it's one
of the coolest things because you've got
the Superman you've got Power girl
you've got all these different
superheroes who were there doing the
best they can to hold him back and at
the end of the day none of it matters
he's still able to take out almost every
last one of them because remember you're
talking about a character who's more
powerful than any current version of
Superman who's faster than any current
version of Superman who's stronger you
know he has more endurance he has a
higher level of durability and there's
no green kryptonite and no red you know
no red Sun within the immediate vicinity
he's virtually unstoppable but the cool
thing about this is that in the middle
of all that he basically gets more than
he bargained for and the reason why is
because due to his arrogance and his
hubris one of the guardians of the
universe sets upon him and then
self-destruct and
makes sense because remember the
guardians of the universe are insanely
powerful and it was really required for
them to act because if they hadn't
stepped in and stopped superboy-prime
none of it would have mattered
superboy-prime
would have destroyed every single Green
Lantern he would have destroyed every
single superhero and there's nothing
that they could have done to stop him
they'd be virtually powerless I mean it
would it would have been the end of all
things and he almost guaranteed to kill
sodam yacht and so it would have set in
motion the death of almost everything in
existence and so what ends up happening
here is that with a battle basically
winding down geoff johns the writer of
the story begins the process of going
through and sort of bringing all these
different themes to a close but also
setting the stage for the next set of
events remember ganthet and sayd despite
the fact that they are guardians of the
universe are separate from the rest of
the guardians they've been outcast
because they one did not agree with what
the guardians were doing and two worked
against the other guardians of the
universe and so the result is that they
basically kind of go off and they do
their own thing at the same time it's
also a bit of reconciliation between the
various superheroes and the Green
Lantern's and helping humanity sort of
get past everything but it's also the
idea the superboy-prime had basically
been shunted out of the existing
universe and sent to a whole nother
universe in its entirety and so again it
almost seems like he's basically been
sent back to his home place but the
issue is that during the events of
countdown to Final Crisis I think it is
it's gonna show that he's actually been
sent to a whole different universe which
is leads to a whole nother set of events
but the other gist of this is that with
ganthet and sayd looking around and
realizing that in the midst of all this
that somebody's going to basically have
to have the ability to help out the
Green Lantern's to offer themselves as
kind of a support group if it's
necessary the two of them in turn bond
their energies and form the blue
lanterns the Lantern Corps of Hope and
so again this is how all this stuff
begins to build that where Sinestro
Corps begins to wind down it's almost
like these peaks and valleys you know
you see this story starting to wind down
into a valley only for the ending to
begin winding up into a peak and we end
up finding these things out because of
the fact that the Manhunter robots
tracked down the remains of Hank Henshaw
and basically resurrect him and it's one
of the saddest things ever because where
he believed that he was gonna be free of
this life that he was gonna be dead he's
instead brought back to life he cannot
ever truly died his Manhunter robots
will always keep him going but the big
jaw dropping moment in this particular
part of the story and the one that
really just kind of left people
flabbergasted was the fate of the
anti-monitor the anti-monitor is a being
that is
so incredibly powerful that he just
can't be destroyed through conventional
means it would take basically that God
of the DC Universe the presence to
really just kind of destroy him in its
entirety but the ideas of the
anti-monitor still resides within the
realm of the quote-unquote afterlife or
at least what passes for the afterlife
in the DC universe and is still
hell-bent on achieving his goal of
taking over everything only for him to
be transmogrified into the singular
power source for the Black Lantern rings
themselves but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
commerce explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah so that's
your core war was amazing but it only
gets better from here that's the
craziest thing I feel like it only just
keeps yeah it keeps getting better and
better especially with blackest night
with brightest day it gets pretty insane
but I will catch you all later peace
[Applause]
[Music]
you